at this point it feels like even
pro-trump people have moved on I mean I
went down to the courthouse today and I
was the only protester there
[Laughter]
Colin Jost gets fooled on Saturday Night
Live
the best thing you've ever done
I was I'm covered in sweat the show
happened to fall on April Fool's Day
this year so his weekend update co-host
Michael Che decided it was a good time
to play a prank on his pal on live
television it's just it's fun it all
started when Collins jokes didn't get
the reaction they usually do when Trump
surrenders New York City Police will
take his official mug shot which you
know is the only thing Trump cares about
getting right I'm sure he's hoping it'll
look cool like Frank Sinatra's but I bet
it'll end up closer to Nick Nolte
notice the mild laughing yeah that
happened
now let's compare the audience reaction
to Michael Trump is reportedly being
charged with 34 counts of business fraud
business fraud is also what they call
the Trump costume at Spirit Halloween
foreign
Biden on Friday told reporters that he
had no comment on Trump's indictment and
then he danced away like the Six Flags
guy
oh yeah big difference and Colin finally
catches on when someone in the crowd
yells
[Laughter]
I told him not to laugh at your favorite
food
[Applause]
and then I was just like oh I just suck
all right moving right along
representative Madre Taylor green you're
evil
we kind of try to find humor in
everything otherwise
there's no other reason for us to be in
comedy Michael's no stranger to pulling
a fast one on Colin on air especially
when it comes to his wife Scarlett
Johansson it's hard to have a lot of
complaints she's pretty awesome Michael
once tricked Colin into making a joke
about his lady love it was announced
that Creed singer Scott staff will play
Frank Sinatra in an upcoming movie but
the good news is Sammy Davis Jr will be
played by Scarlett Johansson
and when it came to the couple's Wedding
Day in 2020 Michael was tempted to pull
a prank then but nicely he held back I
really wanted to interrupt and cause a
huge mess and then I got there and it
was like just a normal people wedding
you know it turns out they're like
actually normal and it was sweet and I
was like I can't mess this wedding up it
seems like a very good sign but that
clearly hasn't stopped Michael from
pulling jokes on Colin on live TV that's
the meanest thing you've ever done
if I was nine covered in sweat
[Music]